cbs news legal analyst rikki kleman
joins us now ricky good morning welcome
to our new set glad to have you here
from the moment these shootings happen
there has been a big political
conversation surrounding it about who's
the villain who's the hero who had a
right to be there but inside the
courtroom it's much simpler it's a
straightforward question about
self-defense indeed it is and the real
issue in this case of self-defense is
solely did kyle rittenhouse act in fear
of his own life and was that action
reasonable the politics should go away
the noise should go away one of the
problems here tony is really about
proving this case to the jury if kyle
rittenhouse had never testified
the burden of proof is
beyond a reasonable doubt solely on the
government to show the kyle rootenhouse
did not act in self-defense
but the government according to most
people who watched every minute of this
trial
the government had a lot of problems
getting up to that burden of proof on
the evidence they had
but once kyle rittenhouse gets on that
witness then the jury are normal people
using their common sense burden of proof
goes out the window all they think about
are two questions do we believe kyle
rittenhouse and do we like kyle written
house saying liking him matters i think
liking him really matters to a juror did
he help or hurt his case yesterday it
depends upon how you look at his
testimony how did he help well to many
people when he had what i call a true
panic attack what happened when he
couldn't breathe when he couldn't talk
when he was it was said crying some
people thought that was fake a lot of
people thought that was fake but people
were looking at that as remorse
it wasn't a question of looking at it as
remorse he was having a panic attack how
do we know that he had panic attacks as
he said when he went to the police
station anyone who's ever had a panic
attack could see that
so
do we feel we being the jury do we feel
for him that he's a 17 year old kid who
found himself in a situation albeit by
his own doing
and that when he felt surrounded and
when mr rosenbaum was coming at him and
mr zaminski was over here and he then
had a panic attack and he believed that
he feared for his own life what about
the judge in the case because he has
certainly become a part of this
conversation for better or worse
many people think that he appears to be
biased against the prosecution is that a
fair assessment on your part i don't
think it's a fair assessment in this
sense i think what this judge is trying
to do is to give the defendant a fair
trial we rarely see that we often see
judges who bend over backwards to give
the prosecution a fair trial here we
have give the defendant a fair trial
even though people may not like it but
one thing is for sure if kyle
rittenhouse is to be convicted this
judge is never going to get reversed
ricky if you can do it in 15 seconds
there is a i want to bring the outside
world back in what is the wider societal
impact of the outcome in this case no
legal impact has no precedent it's a
trial but societal impact big time is
this going to empower people to go to
protest
armed and feel that they should be the
police
or is it going to allow people to feel
that it's okay to carry a gun but not to
a protest do are people going to look at
this as a racial case or are people
going to look at this as a second
amendment gun rights case kyle taking
the stand was a turning point it's a
turning point some people think it was a
great idea i don't like putting
defendants on the witness stand because
they changed that burden of proof
all right ricky clayman thank you it's
really good to have you thank you it's
great to be with all of you nice to see
you in person